multiplica menos 4 x al cuadrado por 3x
cuadrada más 25 x menos 7
ok quieren que multiplicamos un mono mío
por un polinomio entonces tenemos que
utilizar la ley distributiva para
multiplicar pues este mono mío por cada
uno de los monos de acá por cada uno de
los términos entonces hay que
multiplicar este por este luego este por
este este por este y al final sumar
vamos a ver cuánto nos queda al hacer
esas operaciones déjame empezar con este
color verde primero tenemos que hacer
menos 4x cuadrada por 3x cuadradas unos
4 x cuadrada x 3 x cuadrada
y ahora tenemos que sumar lo que nos
queda con 25 x o sea menos 4 x cuadrada
menos 4 x cuadrada x 25 x 25 x y
finalmente tenemos que sumar menos 4 x
cuadrada x menos 7 entonces lo pongo
aquí menos 4 x cuadrada x menos 7 muy
bien vamos a ver cuánto es esto
déjame hacer un paso intermedio
probablemente no lo tengas que hacer
después cuando tengas un poco de
práctica pero ahorita es bueno hacerlo
entonces voy a juntar los números aquí
me queda menos 4
- 4 x 3 menos 4 x 3 x x cuadrada por x
cuadrada simplemente ustedes la
propiedad conmutativa esto de aquí
cuando es esto es menor o sea menos 4 x
3 es menos 12 x cuadrada por x cuadrada
tiene la misma base sumamos los
exponentes dos más dos es cuatro menos
12 x a la cuarta muy bien ya eso tenemos
que sumar este producto déjame ponerlo
así entonces menos 4 por 25 por equis
cuadrada porque x otra vez juntar los
números a la izquierda y las variables a
la derecha menos 4 por 25 es menos 100
menos 100 y equis cuadrada por equis
pues este x lo podemos pensar como x a
la 1 entonces es x al cubo verdad se
suman los exponentes y finalmente vamos
a ver aquí que nos queda nos queda menos
menos cuatro x menos 7 x x al cuadrado y
eso de ahí cuánto es eso de ahí es pues
menos 4 x menos 7 es es 28 entonces es
más 28 x x al 4 muy bien y con esto
terminamos ahorita ya no hay que
simplificar nada los exponentes son
distintos entonces no podemos hacer nada
más y así lo dejamos